pour les élèves et les enseignants le
changement c'est pour maintenant avec la
réforme du collège sur fond de
contestation syndicale le recteur de
l'académie de Versailles a tenu à
défendre ses transformations notamment
d'ordre pédagogique l'aide personnalisée
qui fait que les professeurs vont
travailler avec les élèves par groupe
soit parce que certains ont des
difficultés soit en faisant travailler
ceux qui ont plus plus réussi à côté
d'autres élèves une pédagogie aussi par
projet à travers les les enseignements
pratique interdisciplinaire la réforme
du collège apporterait de la
progressivité dans l'évaluation les
classes de 5e 4e et 3e seront pensé
globalement avec une adaptation du
programme par rapport à l'évolution des
compétences des élèves chaque année
c'est un un processus pendant 3 ans
pendant lequel les professeurs doivent
étaler les acquisitions pas les répéter
chaque année les penser par rapport à un
objectif c'est ça le grand changement
ces changements faciliteraient
l'intégration du numérique dans les
collèges une priorité dans l'académie de
Versailles avec son plan numérique pour
l'éducation le recteur a donné un kit
composé d'une tablette d'un
rétrroprojecteur et d'une caméra à
l'ambassadeur numérique du collège de la
giio ça me permet de beaucoup mieux
cibler de beaucoup mieux différencier
euh mes apprentissages et de de
personnaliser mon apprentissage par
rapport à chaque élève tous les élèves
de 6e du collège de laagion ont reçu une
tablette à la rentrée 24000 ont été
prévus pour cette rentrée dans toute
l'académie de Versailles avec un espoir
à la clé une augmentation de la réussite
des
élèves